- C'est très cher pour nous
maintenant, c'est beaucoup nous
aider.
- La rentrée scolaire est
dispendieuse cette année.
Une conséquence du coût de
la vie qui augmente et des
effets de la pandémie sur
le portefeuille. Plus de
1000 familles ont eu un coup
de pouce mardi et ont reçu
des fournitures scolaires.
Une initiative de la
Mission Bon Accueil.
- J'ai pas de soucis, je ne vais
pas à acheter le sac à dos.
Je vais acheter d'autres choses,
des uniformes et tout ça.
- L'organisme a une longue liste
de familles dans le besoin.
Les demandes d'aide pour
les effets scolaires se sont
multipliées.
SAM WATTS, président-directeur
général, Mission Bon Accueil
- La PCU a eu un effet positif
dans certains cas, puis on a vu
des familles qui n'avaient plus
besoin de nos services. Mais,
en même temps, la pandémie a été
quelque chose... qui a exigé de
certains autres qui avaient des
emplois précaires, à venir
chercher de l'aide. Des gens
qui ne sont jamais venus.
-C'est le même constat du côté
d'Opération Sac à dos, qui
organise une guignolée d'effets
scolaires depuis plus de 15 ans.
ANNE-MARIE ÉTHIER, dir. générale
adjointe, Regroupement Partage
- Si on se réfère à la période
pré-pandémie, donc, nous notre
Opération Sac à dos qui serait
en 2019, c'est une augmentation
de 219%. L'objectif qu'on s'est
fixé cette année c'est
d'outiller 7000 enfants.
Les demandes sont beaucoup,
beaucoup plus grandes que ça
évidemment. On n'arrive pas à
toutes les combler.
- La facture associée aux effets
scolaires varie selon le niveau
et d'une école à l'autre, mais
elle est somme toute comparable
aux années précédentes.
La fourchette se situe quelque
part entre 50$ et 100$, un
montant qui exclut toutefois
les dépenses pour les vêtements
et les manuels scolaires.
Mais il existe des trucs
pour économiser.
SYLVAIN MARTEL, Regroupement,
comités de parents autonomes Qc.
- Les listes se ressemblent
d'année en année. Il y a
certains ajustements à faire,
des fois on n'a pas le choix de
se procurer un certain matériel,
mais la réutilisation... il faut
absolument aller vers ça.
- Dans les magasins, les prix
sont demeurés sensiblement
les mêmes. Mais certains
prévoient une hausse à la fin
du mois en raison de la flambée
des coûts des conteneurs
CLAUDE LESSARD, propriétaire
de la Papeterie de l'Est
- On est avisé que fin août tout
va augmenter de 8 à 20%. C'est
les conteneurs sur les bateaux
qui coûtent vraiment beaucoup
plus chers qu'anciennement.
- Pour éviter de débourser
davantage, il serait donc
préférable de faire ses  achats
d'ici les prochaines semaines.
Et pour aider les familles
vulnérables à l'aube de la
rentrée scolaire, donner
des fournitures en bon état
permettra certainement
de combler les besoins encore
plus importants cette année.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, Montréal